bonjour vous allez bien que notre invité
politique savez-vous même très bien ravi
d'être là l'actualité chargée au
Parlement on va en parler parce que vous
êtes ministre délégué chargé des
relations avec le Parlement des tensant
pendant 20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représentée par Christelle meurtrier
bonjour
Franck on va évidemment parler de
l'actualité au Parlement mais d'abord un
mot sur l'actualité du gouvernement
puisque Caroline caillot a démissionné
du gouvernement en début de semaine pour
une déclaration de patrimoine
sous-estimé a-t-elle dit hier le
autorité a saisi la justice suspectant
d'une fraude fiscale d'effets
susceptibles de caractériser une
infraction pénale on est quand même bien
loin de la République exemplaire
d'Emmanuel Macron quand il a justice
fait son travail et elle n'est plus au
gouvernement mais ça a pas d'impact sur
le gouvernement
Dominique Faure
en arriver là est-ce qu'on peut
accélérer un peu les procédures quelle
manière moi j'ai toute confiance dans la
haute autorité
pour la vie la transparence de la vie
politique on a des pas des échanges avec
la Haute Autorité on justifie on donne
des éléments et puis après il y a une
décision voilà et la décision elle est
manifestement de porter plainte ou en
tout cas de transférer le dossier en
justice la justice va faire son travail
car une Cayenne est plus au gouvernement
on est dans une grande démocratie où les
élus doivent rendre compte sur leur
patrimoine sur doivent déclarer leurs
intérêts pour voir s'il y a pas de
conflits d'intérêt et une autorité
indépendante qui fait son travail et
les ministres ou les députés les
sénateurs les élus on tire les
conséquences
on devrait on devrait s'en réjouir vous
devrez me dire mais c'est formidable
c'est on est dans une démocratie qui
fonctionne il y a beaucoup de pays dans
le monde où ils aimeraient bien avoir un
système aussi démocratique aussi
transparent et qui a des conséquences
aussi importantes mais enfin c'est bien
légitime vis-à-vis des élus on va parler
de la réforme des retraites Elisabeth
borne était tiers devant les députés de
la majorité présidentielle pour parler
de cette réforme est-ce que vous nous
confirmez que le report de l'âge légal
départ à 65 ans serait inscrit dans le
texte écoutez vous savez que c'est
l'objectif qui était fixé par le prénom
de la République dans sa campagne
repousser l'âge légal à 64 ans en 2027
et à
65 ans 2031 donc nous travaillons
toujours sur cet objectif là et il y a
toute une un travail de concertation qui
est mené avec les organisations
syndicales avec les représentants des
groupes parlementaires mais pour mener
une réforme qui soit la plus efficace
possible c'est à dire qu'à pérennise le
financement de notre système par
répartition qui est menacé et les chips
sont claires déficit si on ne fait rien
de 15 milliards en 2030 et deuxièmement
de le rendre plus juste et notamment de
garantir le niveau de vie des retraités
dans l'avenir et pour ça et bien dans un
monde dans un pays et on peut s'en
réjouir ou parce que les Français font
plus d'études qu'avant ils rentrent plus
tard dans la vie professionnelle et
d'autre part notre espérance de qui
grandit et donc on meurt plus tard et
donc il est nécessaire d'en tirer les
conséquences en travaillant tout au long
de la vie plus longtemps sera écrit dans
le texte parce que Emmanuel Macron
évoqué celui de 64 peut-être
essayons de respecter une méthode cette
méthode c'est la concertation l'écoute
et le dialogue on est dans cette phase
de manœuvre on est dans cette phase de
dialogue et de concertation la première
ministre fera un bilan de ces
concertations mi-décembre le 15 décembre
c'est pas j'ai dit mi-décembre avant
Noël voilà et elle aura ensuite
l'occasion donc à ce moment-là pardon de
pouvoir présenter le bilan de ces
discussions et de ses négations et ce
qu'elle en tire comme enseignement suite
à un texte qui sera présenté en Conseil
des ministres en début d'année prochaine
vous avez la date face à la première
semaine de janvier ou plus tard et
ensuite il y aura un travail au
Parlement pour un vote à la fin de
l'hiver au début du printemps et au
Parlement ça sera quand du coup ce sera
le premier texte dans la foule ça sera
dans la foulée de la présentation du
texte en conseil des ministres au début
de l'année prochaine ça sera d'abord
objectif avec comme objectif de faire en
sorte que cette réforme entre en vigueur
à l'été 2023 mais entre en vigueur à
l'été 2023 ça veut pas dire que ça va
s'appliquer à tout le monde en 2023 là
je l'ai égale repoussé à une année un
âge qui n'est pas encore
progressif mais en tout cas elle entrera
en vigueur à partir de 2023 pour que ces
effets bénéfiques sur le système par
répartition et aussi bénéfique sur ce
qui va être mis dans le texte en termes
de pouvoir d'achat des retraités mais
aussi en termes de pénibilité en matière
de carrière longue en matière de de
travail des seniors puisse entrer le
plus vite possible en Ligue 1 est-ce que
vous avez tranché sur la forme que
pourrait prendre ce texte est-ce que ça
pourrait être un vrai projet de loi sur
une réforme des retraites ou est-ce que
ça pourrait passer par un projet par
exemple à un plfssr ça sera un projet de
loi spécifique
nous n'avons pas encore la forme exacte
mais ça sera un projet loi spécifique
parce que nous considérons que cette
réforme nécessite un projet de loi
spécifique
vous pouvez utiliser le 49-3 si c'est un
projet de loi spécifique vous pouvez
faire utiliser après qu'est-ce que vous
allez choisir vous-même que dans
l'absolu on peut utiliser les 49-3 que
ça soit attendez
un 49-3 peut être utilisé que ce soit
pour un texte financier ou pour un texte
classique sauf que pour les textes
classiques on a le droit à un par
session bon là on n'a pas utilisé de 49
session donc dans l'absolu on pourrait
l'utiliser mais notre méthode c'est
trouver une majorité sans recourir aux
49-3 pour voter cette réforme importante
il y a certains nombre de formations
politiques qui l'ont mis au cœur de leur
projet politique je pense par exemple
OLR donc je vous pense qu'on peut
trouver les voies et moyens d'un
rassemblement plus large que la majorité
présidentielle un soutien de République
de celles et ceux qui sont convaincus de
l'importance pour sauver notre système
de retraite par répartition et pour
l'améliorer pour qu'il soit plus juste
et plus équitable de leur réformer avec
une réforme sur lesquelles nous
travaillons de pouvoir nous rejoindre en
travaillant avec nous et en le votant
avec nous dans ces cas-là pourquoi ne
pas dire clairement c'est un projet de
loi spécifique il y aura pas de
rectificatif
mais par contre je ne sais pas vous dire
si ça serait un texte financier ou un
texte classique c'est justement l'objet
visiter parce que ce qui compte c'est
l'efficacité et ce qui va être mis d'une
façon très détaillée dans le texte et là
on est justement dans l'écoute de ce qui
est important de mettre dans le texte ou
pas en plus des grands fondamentaux qui
nous permettront de retrouver un régime
équilibré et un régime plus juste et
équitable alors vous venez de dire que
vous espérez le soutien des républicains
sur ce texte on imagine que vous avez
discuté avec eux est-ce que vous avez
déjà des assurances de certains qu'ils
soutiendront
des retraites bien sûr on discute je
vous l'ai dit on rencontre sur tous les
groupes politiques Olivier du soft dans
des réunions multilatérales dans des
réunions bilatérales moi même j'ai
rencontré avec Olivier Shop et la
première ministre les présidents de
groupe pour parler de cette question-là
donc oui on travaille avec les groupes
politiques on travaille avec les
organisations syndicales d'ailleurs
toutes les organisations syndicales qui
sont dans les discussions et tant mieux
aujourd'hui c'est les LR personne ne
vous a dit ok on vous soutiendra
là-dessus on est d'accord
on dit pas quand on est un parlementaire
et l'air ou pas LR on ne dit pas en
soutien de texte sans connaître le texte
sans voir concrètement ce qu'il sera le
moment donné au moment du vote on voit
bien que notamment au Sénat mais aussi à
l'Assemblée nationale il y a beaucoup de
parlementaires qui veulent réformer le
système de retraite pour les mêmes
raisons que nous donc essayons de voir
de quelle manière on peut bâtir un texte
utile pour nos compatriotes
utile pour le pays et qui permettent de
trouver une majorité large au-delà de la
majorité présidentielle sauf que vous
n'avez pas réussi à mener une forme de
retraite dans le quinquennat précédent
pourquoi cela passerait plus que celle
d'Edouard Philippe qui n'a pas réussi à
faire payer la réforme qui était une
réforme systémique très vaste très
ambitieuse au niveau de la refonte
complète du système des tropiques il a
pas été compris par nos compatriotes
dont acte essayons d'être peut-être plus
pragmatique plus efficace et c'est ce
qu'on propose avec cette réforme qui est
tout aussi juste qui va permettre de
tout aussi tout autant
qui va tout autant permettre de
pérenniser le système mais qui va moins
refondre complètement le système par
exemple il y a un certain nombre de
professions qui ont des caisses
autonomes qui continueront d'avoir des
caisses autonome en revanche on va
réformer les régimes spéciaux parce que
c'est une question d'équité c'est sur le
principe vous savez de la clause
grand-père c'est à dire que c'est celles
et ceux qui rentreront dans les
entreprises concernées par ces régimes
spéciaux qui adhérents au régime général
les autres qui sont déjà dans les
entreprises conserveront le système
spécifique le régime spécial spécifique
je crois que c'est cette méthode là qui
permettra de rassembler au maximum
pédagogie il y a un manque de pédagogie
là depuis plus de peut-être de
simplicité dans la rue alors on a
compris que ce texte allait être allé
arriver pardon en janvier est-ce que le
timing est bon sachant que le
gouvernement dit aussi que ce mois de
janvier va être compliqué pour les
français avec des hausses des prix assez
importantes est-ce que vous ne craignez
pas finalement un mouvement social
autour de cette réforme des retraites
ils attendent qu'on prenne les décisions
qui sont bonnes pour le pays qui sont
bonnes pour eux elle est pas forcément
populaire cette réforme mais ça veut pas
dire que c'est des réformes forcément
populaires c'est bon je dis des vraies
formes bonnes pour eux et bonnes pour le
pays c'est une réforme où personne peut
être surpris qu'on l'amène puisque
prévient un public l'a mis au cœur de sa
campagne nous sommes en responsabilité
pour agir nous sommes responsabilité
pour agir pour protéger nos compatriotes
par rapport notamment à l'inflation et à
la crise énergétique mais aussi pour
préparer l'avenir et c'est cette réforme
parmi d'autres qui nous permet de
préparer l'avenir la question c'est
est-ce que c'est le bon moment pour agir
vont traverser une place difficile quand
il y a des réformes importantes on nous
dit souvent c'est jamais le bon moment
pour agir et ben là on considère quand
ce début de quinquennat fort de ce qui a
été dit dans la campagne fort de la
nécessité d'agir rapidement pour que les
bienfaits les bénéfices de cette réforme
puisse entrer en vigueur le plus
rapidement possible c'est le moment de
le faire le plus tôt possible pas en se
précipitant puisque vous avez que le
temps de la concertation est long on
prend le temps d'écouter on prend le
temps de travailler mais on veut agir et
on est déterminé à le faire autre sujet
la politique migratoire il y aura un
débat à l'Assemblée nationale mardi
prochain au Sénat Marne le mardi suivant
le projet de loi de Gérald Darmanin
d'Olivier du soft sera présenté quand
l'année prochaine toujours
à vous dire là toujours sur aussi une
méthode c'est le prénom de la République
a souhaité la première ministre
également mettre en place une nouvelle
méthode de travail avec le Parlement
cette méthode elle vise à prendre le
temps en amont de la présentation des
textes en conseil des ministres
d'écouter de dialoguer non seulement
avec les parlementaires mais aussi avec
les personnes concernées les parties
prenantes et c'est la raison pour
laquelle il y a aujourd'hui des
concertations qui sont menées par
Olivier du Sud et par Gérald Darmanin
notamment avec les groupes politiques au
Parlement pour
réfléchir travailler écouter à ce texte
sur l'immigration ensuite comme vous
l'avez rappelé il y aura deux grands
débats à l'Assemblée nationale et au
Sénat début décembre et ensuite il y
aura une présentation du texte en
conseil des ministres et un débat au
Parlement c'est finalement une méthode
le moment venu après cette période
d'écoute après ces débats il y aura
l'année prochaine la présentation d'un
texte mais ce sera janvier ce sera le
temps ce sera l'été on va pas concerter
maintenant faire un débat en décembre et
présenter le texte en décembre l'année
prochaine donc vous voyez bien que en
fonction du moment où le texte sera prêt
d'un point au niveau du gouvernement il
sera présenté en Conseil des ministres
et je regarderai avec l'Assemblée
nationale et le Sénat comment caler dans
l'ordre du jour la discussion du texte
immigration ce sera juste d'abord au
Sénat c'est pas acté encore
définitivement mais c'est une
possibilité en effet alors plus près de
nous les républicains présentent demain
leur niche parlementaire vous disiez
tout à l'heure espérer leur soutien sur
la réforme des retraites ce que vous les
soutiendrez sur certains textes qu'il
propose demain dans cette niche écouter
il y a eu un travail de fait entre les
députés de la majorité Olivier du soft
et le rapporteur Julien dive notamment
sur la PPL concernant les retraites
agricoles
des discussions sur les autres sujets
parce que c'est des sujets qui sont à
des sujets importants
[Musique]
des violences faites aux femmes et le
sujet des juridictions spécialisées nous
pensons-nous que les juridictions
spécialistes sont pas une bonne idée
parce que ça éloignerait les femmes des
juridictions puisque il y en aurait dans
moins sur le territoire en revanche
d'avoir des magistrats spécialisés ça ça
nous paraît la bonne solution donc il y
a des discussions sur les retraites
agricoles et sur les retraites agricoles
il y a l'idée de d'essayer de prendre en
compte les spécificités de des retraités
agricoles non salariés pour voir de
quelle manière on peut mieux prendre en
compte la réalité de leur rémunération
sur le temps long notamment sur 25 ans
mais le problème c'est que il y a des
difficultés à consolider exactement ces
revenus sur les fameuse 25 années donc
il a nécessité la vie travaillé avec les
organisations syndicales avec ça veut
dire que la vous mettez votre à la
proposition DLR avec les avec les
parties prenantes avec les partis
politiques et les groupes politiques
mais en tout cas on a envie
d'accompagner
Julien dive et celles et ceux chez LR
qui sont favorables à cette réforme dans
le travail qu'il mène sur le
soutiendrez et a priori Olivier du socle
tu vois d'un bon œil le travail qui a
été fait par rapporteur pour améliorer
son texte autre sujet autre sujet qui
fait débat vous savez on peut pas
demander
aux parties au groupe politique qui ne
sont pas dans la majorité présidentielle
de nous rejoindre sur certains textes et
nous de pas le faire quand il quand
c'est l'inverse d'ailleurs c'est ce
qu'on a fait sur un sujet important qui
est la constitutionnalisation de l'IVG
dans le cadre de la niche LFI la
majorité a voté le texte et Aurore Bergé
a retiré son texte qui devait être
présenté au moment des par le modem
exactement et donc vous voyez ça c'est
un bon travail parlementaire et ça
démontre que la Major pas été
présidentielle ne demande pas qu'aux
autres parties de l'opposition de venir
vers elle mais elle va aussi vers celles
et ceux qui présentent des textes qui
sont des textes constructifs et sur
lesquels on peut s'associer un petit mot
sur l'IVG est-ce que vous le
recouvernement va le reprendre j'ai un
projet de loi ce texte sur l'IVG parce
que c'est pas le même processus
parlementaire
alors c'est ça nécessite la le même vote
en des termes identiques dans les deux
chambres et c'est donc ça le gros
travail qui est devant nous c'est de
faire en sorte qu'il y a un texte
identique dans les deux chambres après
si c'est une c'est un référendum
moi je suis
j'ai été RPR j'ai été UMP je crois au
Golly je crois au contact aussi direct
entre les Français et et le pub enfin
les élus et de de demander aux Français
leur avis à travers leur faire un homme
c'est pas du tout quelque chose qui me
choque mais ce que dit moi je suis pas
sur le principe opposé un référendum
une proposition de loi mais si c'est un
projet loi à ce moment là c'est un vote
au Congrès pour les trois cinquièmes des
parlementaires mais d'abord pour pouvoir
faire un référendum ou faire un appel au
Congrès il faut un vote similaire dans
les deux chambres à l'Assemblée
nationale et au Sénat bah que député
sénateurs travaillent et changent
discute essaye de d'être convergence sur
ce beau projet et de sécuriser qui est
de sécuriser quand on voit dans tant de
pays où ce droit important des femmes
est menacé de sécuriser l'IVG dans notre
Constitution autre sujet qui fait débat
là pour le coup au sein de la majorité
c'est le port de l'uniforme ou d'une
nuit identique à l'école un groupe de
députés Renaissance a envie de proposer
un texte sur le sujet est-ce que ça va
être le cas donc une PPL
écoutez il y a des discussions et c'est
bien légitime c'est un sujet qui est
intéressant on voit que certains pays
l'ont mis en place c'est pas si c'est
vraiment complètement notre culture ici
en France mais c'est bien que certains
députés sont saisis certains sénateurs
on discute pour l'instant je suis pas
certain qu'il y a un texte qui soit
déposé mais on verra bien
un mot sur puisqu'on parle du Sénat sur
les cabines de conseils puisque dimanche
Bruno Le Maire a reconnu qu'il y avait
quelques problèmes un recours abusif au
cabinet de conseil il y a un texte qui a
été voté ici au Sénat pour mieux
encadrer les cabinets de conseils est-ce
que ça va transformer en projet de loi
est-ce que vous allez le reprendre vous
savez que déjà on a réformé en 2018
la relation entre l'État et les cabines
de conseils pour encadrer les choses je
voudrais quand même remettre l'église au
milieu du village c'est à dire que on
est en France le pays qui dans les
grands pays européens a le moindre coût
au cabinet extérieur conseil donc déjà
faut remettre les choses très clairement
en place ensuite on a besoin
ponctuellement effectivement d'avoir
recours à des technologies à des
expertises spécifiques sur des points
particuliers s'agit pas de déléguer les
décisions ou de déléguer les compétences
de l'État des cabinets extérieurs bien
sûr mais de s'appuyer sur des expertises
complémentaires aux expertises de
l'administration pour avoir une
administration la plus pointue la plus
efficace possible on va continuer à le
faire je crois que tous les pays et
toutes les entreprises y ont recours
c'est très bien faut que ça soit encadré
s'il faut aller plus loin bon on verra
bien s'il faut aller plus loin sur
l'encadrement pour l'instant on a déjà
voté un texte comment vous appelez la
majorité présidentielle à poursuivre le
travail à l'Assemblée il y a déjà eu un
travail de fait avec une loi qui a été
votée en 2018 donc on a déjà encadré les
choses
mais faut voir je sais pas il faut le
travailler que il parle élémentaire il
travaille moi ce que je voudrais pas
c'est qu'on soit sur des faux sujets on
a tellement de sujets compliqués à gérer
dans ce monde difficile où il y a une
compétition internationale où on a
l'inflation on a une crise énergétique
on a une crise climatique il y a une
transition technologique essayons de pas
trop perdre de temps sur des faux sujets
ce sujet là est un sujet qui nécessite
de l'encadrement ça a été fait s'il faut
aller plus loin on verra bien pour
autant la France est un des pays qui
utilisent le moins de conseils par
rapport aux grands autres grandes
démocraties européennes alors les
gardons de la mesure et de la modération
alors on parle beaucoup du Sénat c'est
normal sur Public Sénat deux textes ont
été présentés en priorité au Sénat à
l'opnie et le texte NR est-ce que ça va
devenir la règle est-ce que c'est plus
simple aujourd'hui de travailler avec le
Sénat avec l'Assemblée nationale déjà il
y a c'est sûr qu'il y a moins de de
tension il y a moins de
sénateurs qui font plutôt de la
politique du buzz ou la politique du
tweet qu'à l'Assemblée nationale ça je
ne peux pas me dire le contraire c'est
vrai que au Sénat et c'est une tradition
et on peut que s'en satisfaire il y a
vraiment une tradition du travail
constructive du travail posé tout en
déterminé sur ses convictions c'est vrai
que les discussions de la loi locmi sur
les moyens du ministère de l'Intérieur
sur les prochaines années et le texte
sur les énergies renouvelables a été
très productif tant mieux moi je suis
très satisfait qu'il y ait des textes
qui viennent en première lecture au
Sénat et donc de plus nombreux que ce
n'était précédemment et j'avoue qu'en
tant que ministre en charge des
relations avec le Parlement j'y un peu
pour quelque chose et donc on va
continuer mais c'est pas non plus une
règle gravée dans le marbre il y aura
des textes qui commenceront d'abord à
l'Assemblée nationale et pas toujours au
Sénat la dernière question réformer le
fonctionnement de l'Assemblée nationale
justement puisque les députés trouvent
qu'ils siège qu'ils passent trop de
temps au palais Bourbons est-ce que vous
y êtes favorable il y avait déjà des
améliorations avant ce nouvel équilibre
à l'Assemblée nationale qui était
nécessaire là avec cette majorité
relative ça conduit les oppositions est
très présentes donc la majorité à être
très présente aussi dans l'hémicycle et
donc un peu au détriment effectivement
la circonscription du travail en
commission donc il faut trouver un juste
équilibre c'est le travail texte par
exemple c'est d'abord le travail à
l'Assemblée nationale au Sénat est
beaucoup encadré par la Constitution
ensuite par leur règle le règlement
intérieur des chambres c'est lourd et
donc il y a a priori des moyens
d'améliorer le fonctionnement du travail
des députés sans forcément toucher au
texte fondateur la Constitution et
règlement intérieur
la présidente de l'Assemblée et le
bureau il travaille je suis sûr qu'ils
vont trouver des solutions les plus
favorables nous le gouvernement donc
prend notre part à cette amélioration du
travail du Parlement je rappelle qu'on
n'a pas voulu qu'il y ait de cession
extraordinaire en septembre d'ailleurs
c'était aussi bénéfique pour le Sénat et
puis on comme je le disais tout à
l'heure en terme de méthode on prend
plus le temps de discuter on met plus de
temps pour les chambres à discuter des
textes à travailler sur les textes on
fait des textes plus courts et donc on
va continuer à écouter les chambres pour
faire en sorte que les relations soient
les plus fluides et les meilleures
possibles entre le gouvernement et le
Parlement et en suivra tout ça merci
Franck merci merci beaucoup d'avoir été
notre invité la Une de La Dépêche ce
sont les médecins bientôt la
consultation à 50 euros c'est à la Une
de La Dépêche merci beaucoup